jan chan yahoo propose ouayach un
passeport en compagnie du docteur
percheron
le ter nous retrouvons notre train et
nous sommes toujours au japon nous
l'avions testé la semaine dernière je
vous rends la parole eh bien nous
arriverons à la seconde voulu par la
garde
elle connaît probablement au pied du
mont fuji c'est admirable pouvoir
prévoir au japon la seconde il allait
respecter et bien elle est respectée
véritablement à trois congrès
extraordinaire ça c'est un monde de
précisions alors nous allons arriver
vous font fi c'est rare de le voir
découvert ou redécouvert 20 25 jours par
an ce n'était pas une seule à y aller
portier des hôtels qui vous attendent
avec les pats rapide car vous voyez plus
vous avez dit la semaine dernière qu'il
pleuvait beaucoup il sur chaque
parapluie marque et le nom de l'hôtel
même on vous donnait une petite équipe a
rapidement c'est à l'hôtel enfin nous
fait cadeau qui porte une enveloppe là
ce qui fait que si vous êtes étranger
vous perdiez il ya toujours quelqu'un
pour me dire ah vous êtes apte à l'hôtel
ou en paix
on va voir produire voilà les cerisiers
les saisies au niveau ce sont des fruits
des fleurs à ces particules ne sont pas
comme aux fleurs de cerisier occidentaux
et sont à double [ __ ] au c'est
beaucoup plus fourni et une charge des
étals qui tombe au moment où le cerisier
ceux des fleurs et une ante de samouraï
qui revient au sol grâce et ravissante
comme symbole
et se promènent en toute quiétude oui
des morts et blessés ce sont des jardins
lanterne des morts
je pense que ça doit être à nara si je
retrouve bien aux jets admirable qu'il
est beau avec ce mélange de costumes et
les guitares vous lisez notre os x que
le japonais aiment vous où vivre en full
les peuples asiatiques sont
communautaires actuellement et bien on
mange en vous donne des petit morceau de
poisson filet sur des baguettes et
griller leur cru comprendre qu'on ne
meurt pour puisque l'on peut manger crus
du poisson des filets et je vous assure
c'est très marrant mais chaque jour une
voie pour le pique nique on enlève ses
souliers on a un si joli et humidité
années 90 parce qu'on est sur des nattes
il faut jamais salir mais n'a pu tous
âges et alors c'est reyes à l'air libre
élimine le voyait passer les manier
cette même de bon ton le monde voit
beaucoup de sacs tenais le saguenay
supporter à condition que pour finir non
pas une bonne bière alors là vraiment
alors le sac et on prend toute son
efficacité que je dis un truc que vous
venez nous le retrouvons notre héros
voilà j'ai pas là justement le but est
de 7 heures sans manger sans bière il
faut le retenir sont jamais
vous vous voir du ca qui s'est rallié à
voile à tous même aux artistes de la
scène gay l'ange de l'accordéon et de
l'antique fameux chaîne wii cet amusant
presque par deux hommes qui dansent les
familles où sont à part donner plus qu
elle n y des femmes et aux hommes
seraient qu'une famille je pense mais
probablement il aurait gardé cette
vieille femme comme la ligue et à une
danse à l'ancienne le départ un pique
nique et une chose extraordinaire car je
prendre de gants lit de paquets plan
porte alors le temps peur huji
c'est un bon nocturne sans fin oui elle
c'est une représentation de non dits des
danseuses qui sans vieira tic tout vêtu
d'un kimono
c'est mon identité et dans le fond dans
ce big ali ce sont des joueuses de cinq
chaînes ne savent jamais d'une sorte de
guitare qui ressemble à la balalaïka la
regardais ce synchronisme des mouvements
qu'elles sont tout à coup tu les
survoler le même bagage oui c'est
curieux c'est fréquent chez eux
oui et alors à quelques mètres il ya un
autre un autre music hall vous verrez
des japonaises avait que quatre des six
mètres carrés de bikini n'est ce pas
cette coexistence civile et devrait
prendre un coup et je voudrais pas vous
demander ce que vous avez préféré le
truc que j'aime beaucoup c'est là je
vous approuve le reste c'est beaucoup
moins mana
deux d'entre eux changent pas de pointe
tout élan des attitudes en a réalisé à
le mouvement lié à entre elles parce que
c'est un des rares pays où tout talent
grâce ubs était intacte au nom oui à la
première avancée des merveilles du japon
m
voilà
toutefois nous
ce mouvement d'être car présentement je
suis ravi et j'ai eu si vous connaissez
des mois que j'essaye alors comme
instrument le sam chaîne est bien ou le
coteau qui selon bande sans lesquels
sont tendues treize corps dans soit
compagnie bout du compte le livret avec
des plex trois plaques tran la main
droite
qu'est ce sens que son spectre des
plectre d'ivoire qui ont volé sur le
pouce mais c'est le destin
les cordes en soit les condense par oui
et alors c'est l'instrument noble qui a
été donnée par un lieu et qui donne l
sonorité grave
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure le
mouvement se précipitent là l'allemand
alors nous voilà dans un temple shinto
les temples chine tous sont toujours
annoncés par ces portiques et ses
portiques rappelle le ce qui avait été
construit pour que les coques allons que
puisse se percher ces coques qui avait
fait revenir la déesse du soleil
amaterasu au cannet qui n'avait pas
voulu apparaître boudeuse vexé de croix
qu'il y avait dans l'univers une autre
ds
incapable de l'équipe c'est cette
pression l'arrêt dans une grotte et on a
cherché un coq décennies a chanté et
j'ai vraiment hâte riquet elle a ouvert
la porte de la grande plus de se
déplacer la pierre elle est venu et ce
moment là on a laissé derrière elle la
pierre elle ne lui rend pas dans la
grotte elle ne voit là régner sur la
terre de nos oui j'y vais avec un
certain manque de respect qu'ils ont
abusé de la curiosité féminine et alors
ce sont des copies et le conte et lèvres
encore des coques allocution de m 53
mètres de longueur mais plus leur
doivent beaucoup de respect alors à ses
copines mais ce n'est en dépit du
modernisme dans le coeur du japonais
c'est une vieille héritage du passé de
cet inconscient collectif visuel moment
et bien encore de la vénération des
sonneries profondément qu'elle n'y
paraît pour community d'une dépendance
voilà des temps plein et temps je crois
qu'ils n'auraient qui sont à l'ancienne
il ya peut-être vingt six 26 sièges qui
sont construites de la même manière et
tous les bains temps à peu près mans les
reconstruire car on ne lâche rien faire
quelque chose du céou dieu le délabré où
ils ont l'air faits tels qu'ils étaient
amants et la tradition s'est perpétuée
sont les collégiens cette fois ce sont
des collégiens se costument unitaire de
rigueur au japon pour les éleveurs ici
les étudiants
c'est tout ça c'est en bois et les
ajuste récente en bois n'y a pas de
coups tout était cheville s'est uni à
une raison profonde nombre de
construction ces d'une méthode de
construction mais la survivance du passé
y avait pas de groupe
la revoilà des danseuses du des temples
qui dansait des danses sacrées et nous
allons les voir tout à l'heure ses
danseuses qui sont en transhumance est
d'accompagner une de marca matin nous
arrive à jouer au baseball
les gerbes de riz sont suspendus en
offrant nos divinités et la première
poignée de riz qui sera récoltée sera
offerte aux dues en grande procession
c'est la ferme on dit que la tête car
sont encore les grandes les grandes
choses agraire qui sont restés coincés
la nourriture
là on sache on attache des prières à un
arbre que l'arbre ça c'est qui qui est
l'arbre justement à laquelle la ds a
trouvé en sortant de sa crotte
mais il est cité voudrait trouver 3
jouez vos merveilleux et alors le marbre
ils jouent au baseball
à l'intérieur ce sont des jeunes ce sont
des jeunes religieux et la jeune femme
qui est là bas est une danseuse du
temple c'est la prime à la ville kent
oui la place américaine niveau qui se
superposent elle joue qu elle joue à
plein de la hague france dont vous avez
la mare courir elle ne joue pas du tout
lentement regardez
le surtout ce n'est pas le bouddhisme le
shintô c'est l'adoration des anciens
dieux job de l'atmosphère
vous ai montré les érables maintenant y
poussent à côté du dakar le japon seul
pays des cascades vous sépare n'y tenais
lumière se précipitent houdemont pannes
en cascade et jardins et des jardins
tarabiscotée je ne sais pas si vous
savez qu'il existe à paris
we shall local jardin kdj avec sera le
connais j'ai connu a été âpre et à la
porte de saint cloud il émule une
histoire extraordinaire de berkane mais
il a fait venir ces arbres même les
roches ignées accueillir du japonais et
il définit tout de même je crois que
naguère par mourir dans la misère mais
il en est tout ce qu ils veulent
généralement à ce texte c'est un bon
système lundi signant là des ponts dans
les balustrades s'entend là qu on reste
ici aux étangs qui vous appropriez vous
c'est un mystère en fait plein de
mystère mais plein d'âme fauquet les
coins du monde vous préférez questions
mais celui qui m'a peut-être le plus ému
c'est là le plus charmant pas eh bien
vous tard nous finirons sûr c'est sur
ces paroles on vous remercie infiniment
l'histoire du bon jusque là yann régniau
vous a proposé voyage sur passeport
cette émission a été réalisée avec le
concours du docteur percheron et de
solange péters montage pierre michel rey
sont à nick v 10 script nathalie murray
illustration sonore denise glaser